so we talked about how you're likely to
have this kind of Superstar effect in
various Industries winner take all which
I agree with by the way and I I feel
particularly bad for young people
because I think that the folks who are
going to be in position to benefit from
the efficiencies of AI will tend to be
more senior in these organizations uh
you'll you'll have like this layer of
rainmakers tear point where if I'm the
person that the mega clients trust then
I can essentially name my price and then
there's the this entire layer of
Automation and AI but below me and then
there'll be some people that help
Steward the AI and help hone the product
but if you're a young person coming in
uh it seems like the latter is going to
evaporate uh before you get there
especially because yeah no I think I
think that's a very good point um I mean
if you look at the nature of work
it's really the entry-level jobs
that tend to be more routine and
predictable because you know you're just
getting getting started right that's
that's the way organizations have worked
they give you know the you come you come
in your first job out of college and
they give you
something that's routine and predictable
and you get started with that but those
are exactly the jobs that are most
likely to be automated so as you say
that that career ladder I kind of
is you know kind of evaporating and I
think that's been true for a while it's
not just happening now I mean if you
look at the fact that
um you know we've got this this
phenomenon that some people call Elite
overproduction meaning that there are
just too many people graduating from
college and expecting they're going to
get these professional jobs and Aren't
Enough out there which is why you see
people with college degrees working at
Starbucks right as Baristas and that's
turning out to not just be you know a
summer job is turning out to be their
career right and and I think that that's
certainly the impact of technology and
the fact that these these jobs have been
disappearing for some time as well as of
course being outsourced to
to you know other countries is a big
part of that and it's going to get to be
a bigger and bigger problem in the in in
the further future it may result in a
problem of of really developing the the
kind of talent you need at the top as
well like you say right now there are
all these experienced people they're
going to benefit from this but those
people are not going to be there forever
you know nobody lives forever so if we
don't have this career ladder then who
replaces those people is are we really
gonna have ai that can replace CEOs or
or how do people you know get on the
path to getting that kind of experience
if if the jobs
um evaporate so I I think there are lots
of issues for us there
um and I I don't know you know how it
all plays out or or or
um the answers to that but definitely
they're you know there's just a whole
range of issues in terms of the job
market and and which jobs are going to
be there and how we develop the the
skills we need in the future yeah there
there is one field I think is going to
grow predictably and so to the extent
that this is appealing to people
listening to this or watching this
prompt engineer which is trying to find
exactly the right prompt to feed the AI
to get the quality output uh and it and
there are people advertising right now
for prompt engineer positions that will
pay six figures uh and someone compared
it to being able to use Google believe
it or not there was a moment in time
when people couldn't naturally use
Google I yes or like the Google search
was a thing so the better prompt the AI
gets the better the work product so if
you can uh feed the AI in a particular
way you'll actually have a job
um because there's going to be some
other person that wants to access the AI
but doesn't want to think about like
exactly what prompt to give it yeah so
so I mean you look at someone like me
I'm I'm sort of my more recent career
has been a as a writer right I've
written books and articles and stuff
I've all I think I'm a fairly good
writer maybe that's you know a skill
that's not valued anymore right but
actually being able to write the
material is something that the AI will
do but what matters is being able to
write the prompt to get the AI to to
write what you want to write which is
actually something I I am not
necessarily good at at all so so it may
you know not be so good for me good
thing I'm old right now but
um but I mean I worry about that I hope
that you know as a society we don't
stop teaching young people how to write
you know like like that that becomes a
lost art or something because the AI
does it um so this is definitely another
concern you know that we're going to
lose a lot of
skills and capabilities that we feel are
important right
we have a bang up new guests thank you